Bonjour comment allez-vous? Attends j'ai dû tuer les oreilles des gens
Bonjour comment allez-vous? Moi ça va extrêmement bien. Je suis aujourd'hui avec Cyprien
et Seb la frite. C'est moi Seb la frite. Oui moi je suis Cyprien
Et aujourd'hui on joue à "ta mère en slip" Attention! la version mobile
Développé par les gars qui ont fait le "Nope quiz" donc je suis très content. /Absolument
d'avoir fait ça avec eux. Pourquoi on refait une vidéo?
Oui bah c'est vrai
Très bien. Pourquoi on refait une vidéo sur "ta mère en slip" Parce que je n'ai
fais que de perdre. On a fait deux vidéo, je n'ai pas gagné une manche.
J'ai jamais fini premier. Tu poses pas les bonnes questions. Put*in mais ma mère m'a trop dit ça
ça me saoule. Alors petite nouveauté
ajouter des cartes voilà, autant de cartes que nous le désirons
Qui s'en fou?
*rire gêné*
Vous connaissez déjà les règles on a déjà fait deux vidéo. Je veux gagner un round
Je suis un homme?/Oui/ Français?
Oui/ De milieu artistique?
Non/ Non/Je suis un homme politique?/Oui
euh je suis Nicolas Sarkosy?/Non/ Emmanuel Macron?/Oui
Je suis dans un endroit?/ Oui /
En France? / Euh ou ailleurs /Oui ou ailleurs
Je fais une activité dans cet endroit là?/ Oui, voilà
Je fais une activité de, de, deee euh. Merde, merde
Tu avais l'air trop stressé la pression
Oh Put*in j'ai eu le gars, je suis trop content./ Mais mec
C'est abusé du premier coup/oui en 15 secondes
Moi tu vas voir je vais tomber sur un truc genre "le marsupilami" je vais jamais trouver
je suis un homme/Oui/ Je suis un homme...
Pourquoi vous rigolez? Mais tu vois
C'est moi là encore je me fais bai*** Un homme d'un dessin animé/ Non
Il a une tête de dessin animé/ J'existe vraiment?/ T'existe vraiment...
Je suis acteur/ malheureusement/ Je suis chanteur?/ Oui / les gens adorent mes musiques?
Je suis Florent Pagny, je suis Maître Gims, je suis Black M, je suis Renaud
Je suis Lorie
Je suis... Je suis Charlie?/ Non pff/ Alors ça si tu veux
Mec je sais pas, mais mec, put*in je suis pas Renaud?
Mais non, mais j'aurais aimé être Renaud, pour être: *toujours debout*
Est-ce que je suis un homme?/Oui/ Est-ce que je suis connu?/ Oui
Euh est-ce que je suis euh politique?/ Oui
Est-ce que j'ai été président?/ Non
Enfin c'est plus trop...Une sorte
Une sorte.../ put*in, mais ça veut rien dire ce que vous m'avez dit/oui c'est vrai
Oui mais ce personnage là n'a pas de sens non plus/ Mais on t'a invité pour que tu perde
Seb tu comprends?
Je suis dans un endroit fermé?/Oui / Tu paies pour y aller?/ Oui/Ouais
Tu paies pour, euh, c'est un truc de beauté? euh non?
Non. C'est un truc de sportif, pour être beau. /Oui
C'est euh
C'est terminé./ Je suis Soprano./ Non/ Je suis Keen'v
OUI!/ OOOH
OK je suis en train de faire une activité?/Ouais/ C'est un sport?/ Non
C'est une activité relou?/Non
Keen'v qui fait...
Bah je crois que c'est fini pour moi, je, j'arrive pas à trouver/ Non, non
C'est un truc chi*nt? C'est chi*nt?/ Non/ C'est cool?/ Oui, ouais c'est cool
J'ai zéro culture en politique/ Arrête, si, mec tout le monde l'a
Est-ce que je suis Rapha un/ Non
Est-ce que je suis... hahaha
Jaques Langui?/Jaques Langui tu sors ça comme ça.../ Mec et tu dis j'ai zéro culture ahahaha
C'est drôle
Le premier à qui tu penses, homme politique, on en parle tous les mois, partout/ Manuel Valls?/ Non, non/ Tous les mois
Ah Donald Trump!/ Non/ Non aaah mmmh!
Est-ce que je suis français? / Non / Kim Jong-un?/OUII
Il a trouvé, je suis dans ma jalousie/ Oh put*in
Moi je suis Emmanuel Macron qui fait un activité sportive /ouais/ dans un endroit intérieur/ouais
Ah dans l'eau, c'est dans l'eau?/Non/ C'est quoi, c'est un truc où tu cours?/ Non
C'est l'eau sous une autre forme.
Olalala c'est incroyable! Ouaah
Tu l'as tellement aidé!/ C'est de l'eau sous une autre forme! ahahah
Qu'est-ce qui m'a pris?/ C'est un truc qu'on fait en soirée/Oui
Keen'v fume un joint/ Pas loin, presque/ Keen'v boit de l'alcool/ non, non
Keen'v fume une cigarette/ Non/ Keen'v allume un pétard/Non, pas loin
Keen'v
roule un joint! Keen'v roule un joint! C'est ça?/ C'était roule un bédo
Keen'v roule un bédo! /OUIIII/OUAAAIS
C'est la première fois que tu gagnes!/ Ouiii!/ *musique de victoire du jeu*
Non, mais c'est ça que j'aime bien tu vois, c'est persévérer pour réussir
Bon/ T'es insupportable/ Allez vas-y tu peux le doubler mec
Bon, attends, Kim Jong-un/ Une fois dans l'année, c'est pas une fête, une fois dans l'année certaine personne le font
mec, Kim Jong-un fait l'Aïd?/Non, non/
c'est des stars, il y a que des stars/ Attendez c'est une activité.../Attention,
Emmanuel Macron fait du patinage artistique?
Non/Fait du patinage? /non / Quoi? / c'est pas cette formulation
Mr Cyprien/C'est bien une patinoire/ Oui/ À la patinoire!
OUIII! *musique de victoire du jeu*
Eh là, maintenant du coup le dernier joueur a un temps illimité, c'est parti
Non, mais viens on le laisse chercher, on va, attends viens.../ Est-ce c'est un lieu?
Ouais, non, non / C'est un événement?/ Oui!/ C'est à la vidéo City?
Ah c'est un truc caritatif?/ Ouais/ Ouais
Tu vas l'avoir attention / Les restos du coeur?
Bah l'événement des restos du coeur
Ah les enfoirés, donc Kim Jong-un aux enfoirés / OUIIII
Mec, je l'ai eu dans la première vidéo ça m'a rendu fou, frère!
Ok, ouf! Tiens c'est celui qui perd qui commence en premier
OK est-ce que je suis un homme? / Tu es, non/ OK euh, est-ce que je suis chanteuse?
Non, mais tu as déjà chanté / Est-ce que je suis
présentatrice télé? / Non / Si je puis me permettre, c'est fini
OK les gars je suis un homme
Non / Je suis une femme/ Oui/ Je suis connu?/ Oui/ Je suis fictif/ Non/ Je suis réel?/ Oui
Je suis actrice/ Oui/ tout le monde me connais?/ Ouais
Elle a joué dans énormément de... euh je suis Jennifer Lawrence?/
Non/ Put*in. Je suis Kristen Stewart?/ Non
Je suis Cyprien Iov?/ Non/ Je suis... *musique de fin du temps*
Ahhh non!
Je suis un homme?/ Non/ Je suis une femme?/ Oui/ J'existe?
Non/ Oui/ Quoi!?/ Ah non, non, non pardon!/ T'existe pas, non!
Je suis fictif, euh... dans un dessin animé?
Non/ Non?/ Dans un... ah! Un personnage
d'une série?/ Non/ Une série de film/ Fin, d'une série de film
Pourquoi tu répète ce que je dis ça va, je te dérange pas?/ Whaaat?/ *ils s'embrouillent derrière*
Ah! Hermione!
Harry Potter
*musique de la fin du temps* Ah c'est fini désolé!/ Je vais vous défonçer!
OK, juste une.../ Je ne sais pas
Est-ce que je fais partie de la télé réalité?/ Non/ Est-ce que jeeee...
Ah c'est le "e" le plus long du monde! Oui! / Ce "e" était
incroyable!/ Est-ce que je suis présentatrice météo?/ Ahahah
Il s'est accroché à une branche, "man"!
"présentatrice... météo!"/ Attendez les gars!
OK ouff /donc je suis une actrice très connue/ Anglaise, anglophone?/ Non
Non/ Pas anglophone?/ Donc je suis française?/ Bah non
Je parle français dans mes films?/ Oui/ Brigitte Macron?
What?!/ Je ne sais pas.../ Une actrice, mais mec/ Je suis
Mélanie Laurent?/ Elle n'est pas française/ Ah elle n'est pas française mais elle parle français!
Et dans ses films elle parle français? Mais c'est incroyablement dur!
Elle a un petit accent/ Un petit accent? Ah un accent québécois?/ Non
Non/ Ah Put*in osti tabernak j'pensais  qu'j'allais trouver sur c'te question
Je pense que si tu trouve son origine ça va aller vite/ Ouais ça va aller vite
Euh je suis un personnage/ Mais comment t'as fais pour t'en souvenir?/ MAIS TA GUEULE!
Euh je suis
une série de film pour les ados plutôt/ Non pour tout le monde/ Dans Twilight? euh
Non les darons, il te kiffent aussi/ Pardon, euh... Star Wars... Star Wars!
Oui/ Star Wars!/ Je suis Princesse Leia/ Oui!
Je fais une activité/ Oui/ Jouer, c'est un endroit où on joue?/ Oh put*in
Mais arrête de, à chaque fois tu m'embrouille frère!
*Ils s'embrouillent au lieu de répondre à Cyprien*
*musique de la fin du temps*
OK, c'est à toi, c'est à toi!/ Il est insupportable/ Mais à chaque fois il me tape mec...
J'voudrais tellement pouvoir t'aider/ Mais! J'ai envie de vous mettre des...
Des coups d'as comme il dit l'autre là
Alors?/ J'ai pas d'idée!
Vas-y trouve! Un métier, un métier d'aujourd'hui/ Tu connais très bien ce métier
Un Youtubeur?/ Oui!
une Youtubeuse?/ Oui!/ Euh est-ce que je suis une Youtubeuse beauté?
OK, je suis jolie/ Oh oui/ Je suis brune?
Oui/ Je suis Espagnole?/ Non/ Italienne?/ Oui/ Oui
Italienne?! et je parle français?/ Oui
WOUOOOH, pardon, pardon!
Mec j'y croyais pas, je pensais pas qu'elle était italienne
Fin j'ai dit ça au pif!/ Bah Monica Belluci à un moment..!/ Ouais bon ça va...
Je suis princesse Leia et je fais une activité?
Oui/ Un sport quand même?/ Non, pas tellement
Ah c'est pour se faire kiffer un peu?/ Ouais/ J'en ai déjà fais? Vous en avez déjà fait?
Moi, j'ai jamais fait, moi/ Moi j'en ai déjà fait/ Lui il en a déjà fait
Ouais, c'est les beauf qui le font/ Ouaais/ C'est ça!
Ahahah désolé!
Tu euh../ C'est fini, non mais arrête/ Est-ce que je suis Youtubeuse beauté?
Non/ Euh Youtubeuse humour?/ Oui/ Est-ce que je suis Natoo?/ Oui!
Est-ce que je fais une activité?
Pfff, non/ Tu fais pleins d'activités/ Je suis... c'est un état?
Non/ Attends mais.../ Si un état, non, non,.../ Ah il s'énerve!
Mais attends oh/ Est-ce que je euh
Ah non c'est à moi. Ok,  je fais un sport?
Bah oui/ Je suis Monica Belluci qui joue au foot, qui joue au baseball/ Non/ qui joue au tennis?/ Non
Au badminton? Qui joue au Crocket? Qui joue aux croquettes?
Qui joue à lancer une bille sur la tête de son frère et ça fait un bruit drôle?/ Oh non!
OK, je suis Monica Belluci qui... Mais put*in, mais c'est pas possible
Mec t'es passé tellement de fois à côté, à ta place j'aurais trouvé direct je pense
Quoi, quoi, pourquoi tu me coupes la parole?/ au camping?
À la pétanque? Fait un sport/  *ils s'embrouillent sans répondre à Cyprien*
*non mais t'es insupportable mec, c'est fou!*
*Non mais on va régler nos comptes là-bas mec!...*
Je fais une activité, je suis en train de faire un sport? C'est en intérieur
Attends on participe un peu et après on s'embrouille. Indice, c'est souvent dans une salle des fêtes
Ah ben là il va carrément trouver/ Est-ce que c'est de la télé réalité?
Oui!/ Est-ce que c'est Natoo qui fait les, euh, les "Chti's"?/ OUI!
Je suis Natoo qui fait les Chti's/ Exactement/ Oui!/Put*in c'est incroyable!
Je suis Monica Belluci qui fait un 500 mètre haie/ Non
Je suis Monica Belluci qui fait un mille mètre respiration induction/ Non
Je suis Monica Belluci qui fait du lancé de poids/ Non/ Qui fait.. AAAH!
À claques fois que  je dis plein de sport.../ Je suis Princesse Leia
Qui joue au Bingo! Qui joue au Bingo!
*Il te manque un gros truc essentiel*
De quoi tu parles?/ Je joue au Bingo?
J'ai jamais joué au Bingo/ Il nous demande si on a déjà joué au Bingo
T'as déjà joué au Bingo toi?
Je joue au Bingo ou pas dites le moi!/ Tu veux jouer au Bingo?
OUI!/ C'est ça, oui!
Aller, il fait froid quand tu fais ce sport, aller c'est parti! /
Je suis Monica Belluci qui fait du ski/ C'était "en ski"
YEPAÏ!/ Au putain!/
Les mecs, les mecs, les mecs, écoutez- moi bien: celui qui gagne celle-la,
il a tout gagné!
Mais il gagne quoi enfaite, c'est ça que je n'ai pas compris/ Ah non, non rie/, Ah d'accord!
OK Go!/ Est-ce que je suis un homme?/ Oui/
OOH!/ Est-ce que je suis connu?/ Oui
Est-ce que je suis un dessinateur/ Non/ Est-ce que je suis
un sportif?/ Non/ Est-ce que je suis un, un concessionnaire?
Est-ce que je suis Marseillais?/ Non
Non mais mec/ Elle est hyper dure frère!!
Je suis un homme/ Oui/ Je suis réel
je suis réel, attends, je suis réel
Je suis ???, je suis un acteur?/ Bah non, ahaha
Je suis un homme politique?/ Oui/ Je suis Emmanuel Macron?/
Je suis Kim Jong-un?/ Non / Sa mère!
Je suis un pharaon, je suis Nicolas Sarkozy/ OUIII!
Je suis Nicolas Sarkozy qui... fait tourner les serviettes
je suis un homme
Non/ Il y a un doute?/Pourquoi tu fais..? ahahah
Il y a un doute, je suis une femme?/ Oui, oui
Je suis célèbre/ Pourquoi tu..?/ euh je suis dans le divertissement.../
Oui, tu divertis les gens/ En France?
Oui/ Sur Youtube?/ Non
On l'a vue il y a pas longtemps elle avait beaucoup changé/ Mec, tu peux le faire
Je te donne un indice, je suis un bon gars/ Ah bon?/ Il a fait une polémique de fou
Ah mais c'est trop simple/ mais incroyable/ Edouard Philippe?
Edouard... quoi?! / Il a fait une polémique aujourd'hui
Ouais mais euh une polémique de quatre seconde euh/ il nous sort un truc qui date de 1 heure
Euh Dominique Strauss-Kahn/ Non/ Woah
Dominique Strauss-Kahn mais puissant de fou quoi, beaucoup plus puissant/ Ah Weinstein
Ah je l'ai pas/ Ah c'est dommage, tu pourras pas gagner cette partie/ Quoi ahaha?
okay je suis Nicolas Sarkozy, je fais un sport/ Non
Je suis au ski/ Non/ Je suis sur un télésiège?/ Non
C'est vraiment un endroit genre il pourrait être dans la salle de classe
ça pourrait être ça?/ Oui c'est un endroit/ Okay il y en a en France/ ouais
il y est à Paris?/ Il est à Paris/ Okay, je suis Nicolas Sarkozy à l'Elysée
Oh le fils deeee...
Oh j'ai pété mon doigt sur cette tablette
Mec, c'est ouf, c'est comme si le destin voulait que je gagne la partie qui fait gagner tout!
Une femme/ oui/ qui diverti il y a longtemps/ oui elle est veille, elle est décédée
non!/ Elle est toujours en vie
Elle a arrêté son activité on a fait "mais?!"
on l'a revue à la télé, on a fait: "mais?!"
OH!/ C'est trop ce que t'as dit/ OH
C'est Loana?!
Ah non!
ahahahah
Est-ce que vous m'accepter Weinstein sans prénom?
Tel que tu es, t'inquiète/ Harvey Weinstein, c'est validé!
Est-ce que c'est un truc qu'on fait quotidiennement?/ Ouais
Moi je le fais/ Moi je le fais énormément/ Est-ce que c'est Weinstein qui fait des pompes?
Tu te doutes bien que non/ Malheureusement/ Est-ce que c'est Weinstein qui touche une femme...
euh ahahha
Il y a que des trucs Obvious tu sais
euh, je suis
une femme, ça fait longtemps
qu'on l'a oubliée/ Ouais/ Elle est comédienne/ Non/ ah elle fait de la télévision, elle fait de la télé réalité!
Non/ Ah du chant/ Oui/ Elle est chanteuse
Oui/ Fallait pas qu'elle revienne/ Bah,/ Elle est pas revenue enfaite
Elle est partie/ Elle est jamais revenue
OK vas-y go
Est-ce que c'est chiant comme activité?/ Oh c'est agréable quand tu le fais mais autour les gens ils font: "Oh..!"
Je l'ai probablement fait plusieurs fois dans cette vidéo/ Weinstein qui rage/ Ah bah merci c'est gentil
Albert Weinstein qui perd/ Non
Albert!/ Mais Albert arrête c'est Harvey!
Ah je suis Lorie!/ Non/ C'est la même période par contre!
Mais elle est un peu "ghetto" plus/ Ghetto? je suis Diam's/OUIII!
Oh stylé, c'est vrai qu'elle a vraiment arrêté/ Harvey Weinstein en train
d'émettre un signal sonore/ Non/
Est-ce qu'il fait une activité liée à
au web?
AHAHAHAH
Put*ain je ne comprend rien
Vous m'avez fais perdre tout mon temps
Attends pourquoi ce serait drôle?
Ton coeur s'est arrêter quoi!
Je suis frustré, je veux savoir/ Ah c'est lourd!
Je suis Diam's dans un endroit très particulier, un peu partout dans le monde
Non l'endroit est pas particulié mais l'activité oui
-Tu l'as déja fait toi ? -Noon -Moi j'ai jamais fait moi
-C'est une activité alors ? -Wai - c'est vraiment un truc précis
-Du divertissement s'amuser -Nan -aucun plaisir
-Si du plaisir -Si Si
-A la recherche de plaisir
-Dans un SpeedDating -J'suis Diam's dans un SpeedDating
*Squeezie et Seb La Frite Choqué*
-Comment ta fait ?? -Mais comment recherche de plaisir
-J'ai gagné -Oui
Aller Albert AHAHAHAHAH
Aller Albert Einstein [vas-y(x5)]
-Donc Harvey Weinstein
-C'est des choses que vous faîtes souvent ?
Moi je le fais souvent parcequ'en faîtes c'est un toc
Et... voila
Mais les gars c'est hyper dur
-Non c'est pas dur -Non ça va mec
-Vous êtes des bat*ards -ça va en vrai il n'y a rien de dur frère
-Et Je suis Harvey Weinstein qui... qui lit ?
-Non
-C'est incroyable Non ?
-Aller -qui joue a ta mère en slip
NON
-Le meilleur moyen de cloturer cette série de vidéo était de gagner
-La game qui te fait tout gagner -Exactement
-Merci à tous les gars
Le jeu m'a un peu aidé
j'crois qu'il a eu pitié de moi
N'hésiter pas à aller voir la chaîne de Seb qui nous a fait le plaisir de nous procurer un fou rire colossale dans cette vidéo
passer voir la chaîne de Cyprien N'hésiter à aller sur le playstore ou l'appstore pour télécharger le jeu
-C'est amusant - 1€ et quelques voila
*Musique de Fin*